jay-z says cancel culture is here to
stay and feel
sorry for the younger generation it's
unbelievable metro uk story
jay-z has shared his thoughts on the
internet canceled culture and predicts
it'll be around as long as social media
access castle culture has been discussed
increasingly
in recent years and involves large
groups or fandoms deciding
to essentially erase a celebrity or
public figures career in public
uh prominence in light of a scandal or
controversial issue the paper explained
how he feels sorry for the younger
generation growing up in a social media
era explaining
you can't give someone a microphone for
24 hours a day and have them not think
that they have to use
use it the key these kids it's
unbelievable imagine having a microphone
and you're asked about social justice
questions
at 18 years old it's like what i'm meant
to answer
i'm i'm meant to know the answer and if
you don't
if i don't answer the correct way if i
don't say any
everything right even if i mention my
intentions my intentions are right
and i don't say the same right thing
it's going to be everywhere
i mean he's got a great point there yeah
i was impressed i was really impressed
but do you
agree that it's here too okay let me say
that that's the point you know what he
could have taken two routes there he
could say
it's here to stay or this is temporary
and it's going away i applaud him
i thank you jay-z for saying it's here
to stay and i'll tell you why because i
think
he identifies it as a fringe element
okay
like he minimizes a little bit by just
saying okay it's not going to go away
there's always gonna be young people
social media
isn't leaving so don't take it too
seriously if he said this thing's gonna
go away
it's not and then you legitimize it i
think now you can just look at these
people that are doing this
fringe element they're wackos they're
always gonna be around you know move on
nothing to see here no i agree
and that's happening even with with me
with the campaign and i think that's
happened to so many
you know celebrities and people in the
past you do have to just look over it
you have to understand that it is it
isn't going anywhere but you
i think that does minimize it and take
away a little bit of the the flame that
they were having and just as you said
like
why give in to them why make them matter
even more so
and with me is it's hard because i want
to like protect myself and just
say certain things and it's like a
double-edged tour because they
screenshot and use it for more content
so i call them content predators as well
well i think we've established that
anyone can be a media company these days
any
16 year old with the phone hey welcome
to the joe blow show and here's my
thoughts
i think we can all agree that citizen
journalism is what they're calling
ppd at 18 major at 18. tom and 18.
adam at 18 is a lot different than adam
at 38 42 45
big time your your thoughts and your
everything evolves
and at this point with cancel culture
they're going back
well he said this in 1994
so we got a cancer right look at his
twitter account yeah look at us
so like i think
it that everything is so out there these
days that
you just need to be careful what you
said and i think that's essentially what
jay-z is saying
i don't i actually i'm on the opposite
side i don't want to be careful yeah i
i don't i don't i don't know about that
because let me tell you you're arrested
when you're like that you're walking on
eggshells when you're like that look i
get it like listen
there is like we talked about the other
day there is 98
of things we'll talk about openly then
we've got the two percent that we're
probably not going to talk about on
camera
i get it we'll talk two percent you know
it's gonna be a different conversation
everybody has that small percentage so
it's one percent something that's two
percent some is ten percent closer to
one but um you're closer to maybe two
three
i think that's a fair assessment i'm not
running for governor i'm not running for
donald trump
but now you're you're living in a time
that people are being told to be closer
to 50 percent
so meaning just be fake on the camera
just be fake don't tell what you think
just be funny
but
[Music]
yeah again i i think i think
people still want the realness i think
what people
want is for you to be able to stand
against the heat and say okay listen
somebody said this
about you let's see what you're gonna
say about it okay cool we'll respect you
when i took the argument
you lost seven of the 28 arguments you
want 21 of them
fair cool we're good to go let's move on
to the next and then they get over right
cancer culture is also predicated based
on how the individual handles the cancer
culture
when they're being cancelled it also has
to do with that because jay-z is
probably right it probably isn't going
away
in a very very long time uh of people
being canceled so if you enjoyed this
little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye